new video obtained by the eight news now
investigators shows what one group is
calling abuse of wild horses now we do
want to warn you this is graphic you can
see in this video a wild horse escapes
after being captured and then it limps
with what appears to be a broken leg
despite that though it's chased by both
a helicopter and this man on Horseback
now this is all during a
government-funded capture of wild horses
happening near Elko there are two
operations currently underway the group
Wild Horse education which has fought
against these operations says that horse
was then shot and killed the group is
demanding the BLM stop these roundups
immediately